quisiera comenzar por lo que es táctica
no tácticamente hablando por qué Ucrania
insiste no en la necesidad de contar con
los tanques leopard
Bueno hay que decir que los carros
leopard son en conjunto superiores a la
mayor parte de los carros que Rusia ha
desplegado en el teatro de operaciones y
que de Cara a una posible ofensiva en
fuerzas especialmente la zona que se
espera que sea que será Desde esa
polilla hacia meritopol es necesario
contar con una serie de vehículos que
tengan fuerza y pegada y que sean
capaces de alcanzar el objetivo
rápidamente y esos son carros de combate
de Última Generación y En comparación
con los que posee el ejército ruso Qué
ventaja representa en este tipo de
vehículos
hay que ver distinguir entre si es el
leopard 2 a 4 o leopardos a cinco a seis
porque hay diferencia entre ambos el
leopardos a 4 está más igualado con el
carro más moderno que tiene Rusia en
servicio que es el t90 Aunque solo tiene
una 100 unidades del mismo y el huevo
haya sido destruido pero en conjunto son
vehículos que tienen mayor movilidad
mayor blindaje tiene más protección de
Cara a la hora de recibir un impacto y
sobre todo su sistema de punterías y de
cámara térmica de visión son superiores
a los carros rusos Entonces
evidentemente les permiten localizar
objetivos a mayor distancia y abrir
fuego a mayor distancia Pues con mayor
eficacia teniendo en cuenta todo esto
que nos estás diciendo los leopard
podrían hacer una diferencia inclinar la
balanza a favor de Ucrania en la guerra
Sí pero con condicionantes lo que no se
Comenta del todo es que el carro no
opera solo es decir el carro es un
sistema de armas que opera en conjunto
con otro vehículo blindados con
Infantería que deben de acompañarle con
vehículo de ingenieros que le abren paso
abren los campos de mina ayudan a pasar
obstáculos Y con una cadena logística
detrás bastante importante y aparte
también con artillería con profundidad
suficiente para acompañar El Avance de
estos carros si estos carros se
suministran en número suficiente y con
todos estos equipos que estoy diciendo
junto con ellos pues realmente no van a
ser una ayuda significativa
evidentemente ayudarán porque es mejor
que no tener nada pero no va a ser el
arma maravillosa como todo el mundo está
pensando ahora Lucas como informamos
previamente el ministro de defensa de
Alemania está alentando un proceso el
comienzo de un proceso de entrenamiento
a las tropas ucranianas para utilizar
este tipo de vehículos un entrenamiento
que se varía semana por lo menos 6 según
ha trascendido Cómo afectaría esto el
curso de la guerra
Bueno estamos hablando de seis semanas
para instruir a los tripulantes es decir
al conductor al tirador al jefe vehículo
y al cargador pero después hay que
adiestrar las unidades operar con los
carros un carro opera solo en el campo
de batalla como he dicho antes tiene que
aprender o adiestrarse a operar en
grupos de armas combinadas el tipo
Batallón como mínimo Y eso ese
adiestramiento para ayudarle a aprender
a manejar el carro en estas
circunstancias son meses hablamos
estamos hablando de cuatro o cinco meses
como mínimo para obtener un nivel mínimo
de adiestramiento Para poder operar los
carros